the jurgen experience if you look at the
bill
that was passed i mean i went over it
last night and it's
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] in there
like why are we giving all this aid to
foreign countries in this bill
why is there a part of this aid bill
that uh
makes it a felony to illegally stream
like how does this have they sneak
things into these [ __ ] bills
these people are monsters they really
are like this should have been a real
clear-cut thing
aid to people that have lost all their
income because of this they need a
stimulus
the fact that they they added in a a
felony provision for people who stream
movies and profit from them like what
the [ __ ] is going on like how is
you're not going to hear me disagree
look why is pakistan getting money
why is israel getting did you see it
jamie it's bizarre
i don't understand the logic behind it i
understand how this got agreed to well
what happens is the idea is this thing's
going to pass anyway so you you help out
your favorite lobbyist whether you're a
democrat or a republican you sneak
something in
is that what it is yeah that's clearly
[ __ ] people
here here's what i'll say okay this is
why tell your children actually matters
in this debate
okay i wrote this book and
you can and you can say that's the pot
book folks yeah
you can say like this guy like he
doesn't understand a lot of people just
like to get high and they can handle it
it shouldn't be criminal
um and you know minorities bear the
burden here it's wrong
let's legalize okay totally reasonable
and by the way alcohol kills a whole lot
of people it's legal it's advertised on
tv
it's legal the rules should be the same
i totally get that
okay if you read the book
it's about something else it's about
this is psychiatrically harmful
to a lot of people and we're not talking
about it yes and by the way there's a
downstream violence that comes from that
sometimes that we're not talking about
either
okay to me those things if you read the
book with an open mind are pretty
factual and inarguable it doesn't mean
by the way that you can't then say
cannabis should still be legal you can
read the book and agree with it and say
but you know what should still be legal
for those other reasons
fine that is not the way the book was
treated last year
okay it was you hate black people
you don't understand science you're
cherry-picking
go to hell okay so when i saw this
happening this year with kovid
and i saw the new york times where i
used to work and you know what
people can yell at me for saying i used
to work there but i worked there for 10
years and i was a really good reporter
there
and i'm not going to back down from my
credentials because i am a good reporter
you can say you can say
you know what like lockdowns are
necessary and we need to protect these
old people
and you know what we can't let the
hospitals get overrun
but if i present evidence to you that's
contrary
don't just shout at me that i'm an idiot
and don't know what i'm talking about
okay it's not gonna work it didn't work
with tell your children
and it's not gonna work this time okay
so
and what i recognized was that
unfortunately and sort of the elite
levels of the media
you know the times washington post npr
cnn the group think is overwhelming
yes it's overwhelming on cannabis and
it's overwhelming on all these woke
progressive issues and it's gotten
much much worse since i left the times
ten years ago and i don't know what's
going to turn it around okay
and and and it has terrible effects let
me give you one example okay
we should all want to know where this
virus came from i don't care whether
you're republican or democrat liberal
conservative
i don't care what country you live in
you should want to know if this is the
result of a chinese lab accident
and there's some evidence that we can
talk about that later okay
and you should at least want to know
that there's been a complete independent
investigation into this
okay this thing has messed up the world
in a mammoth way this year
okay and at the least we should want to
know where it came from if it did come
from some kind of accident i'm not
saying the chinese released it
intentionally
i'm saying there might be evidence that
there was an accident because if that
happened
we better make sure it never ever ever
happens again
that's a very strange thing to me that
people don't want to even investigate
they don't want to look at it and
they're they're i think they're afraid
of racism or something
there seems to be some sort of
indication that there's a victim blaming
thing
there's a there's an aspect to it that
also is anti-trump that's it
yeah it's anti-trump okay yeah what
happened in march
was the progressive media first of all
they were terrified because of what was
happening in new york what seemed to be
happening in new york
and they all thought they were gonna die
and then once they realized they weren't
all gonna die they realized that they
could beat donald trump over the head
with this
and he would lose the election and they
did and he did and look i i'm neither
republican nor a democrat
what are you i'm an independent
basically i basically as i've said
my politics are that it's impossible to
be too cynical just like you said with
the with the bill that they just passed
it's impossible to be too cynical about
the way these people behave they behave
they behave terribly okay but so
why is it that the new york times won't
even write stories
about the fact that there's real
questions about where this virus came
from forget the ventilators forget the
us response forget
you know donald trump we should be
asking that question the group think is
so serious that
basic questions don't get asked right
now well we were criticized on the
podcast because i had brett weinstein
who's an evolutionary biologist
who discussed all the reasons scientific
reasons
why it's there's there's evidence that
indicates
that this is not a virus that naturally
occurs that's right
and also just by coincidence there
happens to be a level four lab
in woohans what are the odds right like
you would think that people would want
to put those two together but
it was something from the beginning that
this group think
was established that you are not to
question that and there was a whole
article written about
i'm promoting this dangerous conspiracy
theory that the
the that this came from a lab that's
been disproven but it hasn't been it has
not been disproven
at all no it hasn't been disproven
there's there's there's never been
a real solid proof of where this has
come from that's right here nor there
that's right and and actually you'd say
the evidence
is sort of going the other way now i
mean in favor of this be
and here's why if this thing is
originally came from some animal right
we know that there was a virus that was
96
similar to it that they had at that lab
okay
but we've never found the virus that's
99 similar
in an animal which is what we would
expect to find okay that there'd be
something
really close that then made the jump
from whether it's a civic cat or a bat
or a mink or whatever to a human they've
never been able to find that why was the
connection with pangolins
so so the virus is 96
uh bat it looks like very very similar
and then
near the most important part of it the
part of it that binds to this receptor
on your cells that enables it to get in
it's called the receptor binding domain
is pangolin
okay so it just happens that it's a
perfect
cut of mostly this virus that we know
was in this lab this bat virus with a
pangolin virus
with a tiny addition that it that
enables
um it enables the spike to attach
more efficiently okay it's called the
fern cleavage
and and again we're at sort of the
limits of my knowledge i don't want to
talk too specifically about it
but somehow this virus just happens to
be mostly bat
a little bit pangolin and we can't find
any
evidence of a virus that's like that to
a 99 percentile
in the wild and believe me don't you
think the chinese have looked in the
last year or wouldn't they have looked
if they thought they could find
something
when sars came the original sars not
stars cove 2
they had found the viral host within a
matter of months i mean the
the the zoonotic one the the animal
viral host
in a matter of months and they published
a paper on it there's been nothing like
that
now you can choose to believe that's
because you know what it's just in some
cave in china that they haven't found
the real thing yet
or you can choose the question as you
said there's this level 4 bsl lab
in wuhan where it happens where this
thing happens to seemingly have emerged
from
coincidence coincidence crazy
coincidence yeah but we're not allowed
to talk about that
yeah if you talk about it you're a trump
supporter catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience